[Music]
on this Thursday night rescues become
more rare buried for more than 80 hours
the living are still being found but
hope is dwindling in the earthquake zone
plus what survivors are forced to endure
the investigation into that Quebec bus
driver turned accused murderer what a
neighbor is saying about him new insight
into the Saskatchewan stabbing Rampage
what this 9-1-1 call reveals
global national with Donna freezing good
evening and thanks for joining us there
is lots of news to get to tonight we
begin in turkey and Syria where as time
passes hope is diminishing the death
toll from the earthquakes is staggering
more than 20 000 people are now known to
have died and as the search enters its
fourth night more bodies are being
recovered survivors are left with sorrow
one man said there is no family without
pain each death an individual Agony and
combined a sea of utter Sadness the
sheer scale of the human loss in turkey
and Syria evident in the multiple Mass
Graves that are being dug and hundreds
of thousands of the living are homeless
trying to survive in cold wintry weather
tent cities are being erected in
stadiums and shattered City centers and
search teams are not giving up not yet
[Music]
a six-year-old boy was buried for almost
80 hours he tells Rescuers his body is
aching he asks for water they worked for
hours and they finally freed him one
victory in a sea of despair
another part of turkey this child was
rescued after 83 hours in the rubble and
moments later the mother emerges too but
as everyone knows as time passes moments
like these are increasingly rare our
Jackson prosco is in one of the hardest
hit areas tonight Jackson
Donna the town of pizarchik is right
near the epicenter of the earthquake
residents tell us that rescue workers
only showed up today and Aid has been
slow to trickle in across turkey those
frantic searches continue some yielding
Small Miracles most delivering
heartbreak when the earth shook in
pizargic little stood a chance high
rises were knocked off their foundations
tossed into the street buildings
crumpled in the middle of the night
apartment blocks tipped whole onto their
sides leaving behind only traces of the
people who once lived inside
Rescuers are only now beginning to
search through the rubble here
many many buildings have collapsed I
cannot say that the AIDS and the rescue
teams have arrived on time there are
still dead bodies under the rubble
there's so much needs for further
assistance there are also survivors like
this nine-year-old girl found alive in
the rubble her Rescuers were visibly
stunned by the Disco recovery every so
often the Frantic digging stops so that
Searchers can listen for signs of life
they're increasingly scarce each passing
moment Narrows the odds of another
miracle and when the dead are found
they're buried quickly in Mass Graves
with a disaster of such scale there's
little time to mourn
um
the gravity of this event is very
deplorable doomsday itself says this man
for the living desperation is quickly
setting in crowds Gather in the bitter
cold for blankets clothing and food
they're desperate for anything that will
help carry them through
while tents are provided by the
government survivors still have to fend
for themselves in makeshift camps
people should be helping each other
there are many injured many in bad
conditions says this woman almost
everyone is in need of help there's no
heat and not enough food recovery is
just a dream for a country still living
through a nightmare because so many
buildings are now uninhabitable turkey
is undertaking a mass relocation of
citizens from the hardest hit areas by
Road Rail and air tens of thousands of
people are on the move to safer parts of
the country
Donna
Jackson prosco in pizargic turkey
tonight thanks in Syria things are even
more chaotic than turkey millions of
people's lives were wrecked by a decade
at War they already relied on Aid to
survive now sanctions against the
government of Bashar al-assad have made
getting International Aid into Syria
complicated damage caused by the Quake
has made Transportation difficult too
today the first United Nations Aid
trucks carrying building supplies and
hygiene kits were dispatched as Ross
Lord reports Aid can't get there fast
enough
it took three days but a precious
delivery has arrived bread and other
life-saving supplies the first since the
earthquake leveled parts of Northwest
Syria that were already devastated by an
ongoing Civil War we've reached nearly
45 000 people through this mechanism
within a few days working through this
network of community volunteers and
partners millions of people here have
relied on humanitarian aid for years
amidst the ongoing conflict many already
homeless along with the earthquake's
growing death toll there are even more
displaced syrians sleeping wherever they
can and desperate for water and heat in
a freezing cold winter where Syrian
refugees who found a better life in
Canada it means more anguish my family
they are okay and they are sleeping in
the cars because
it's not safe to get back to to to their
houses Nadal izedine is connected to the
white helmets the Syrian volunteer group
that's clawing through debris to save
lives as a refugee he's not permitted to
return to his Syrian Homeland what I'm
trying to do to go back to to Turkey to
help the white helmets and the logistics
and any any support I can provide as
rescue operations continue maintaining
the flow of relief supplies requires Aid
agencies to negotiate with multiple
parties in Conflict zones it's going to
slow our ability to replenish the stocks
to extend over time when people run out
of their early response supplies that
we've given them and that is an area
where we are calling on the parties to
the conflict to recognize the
humanitarian access hunger is not a
political issue hunger is a human issue
how much and how soon Comfort arrives
for others is unclear
Ross Lord Global News
in Laval Quebec a makeshift Memorial is
growing outside of daycare as people
grieve the children who died when a city
bus driver drove his bus into the
building tonight prime minister Justin
Trudeau the premier of Quebec and the
mayor of Lavelle joined members of the
community at a vigil for the two
children who lost their lives and the
six others who were injured there is a
little bit of good news two of those
injured children were released from the
hospital this morning that was turia
Israel reports many questions remain
about the driver of the bus and what
motivated him
the Laval Transit bus that rammed into a
daycare and shattered lives was towed
away from the crime scene
children both just four years old were
killed in what Witnesses describe as an
intentional crash this father was
dropping off his two-year-old son at the
time we heard the screams and it was
I was the first under the bus he rushed
in and pulled kids to safety couldn't
really see stuff it was very dark so I
kept screaming for a light light because
I wanted to see if I was taking
something out that wasn't going to hurt
anybody
but it happened so fast
and that last girl that I took out was
very hard to take she was really stuck
six children were sent to hospital
this mother left the daycare just 10
minutes before the moment of impact her
daughter survived but the family knew
one of the children who did not
Quebec's Premier visited a growing
Memorial at the crash site and tried to
comfort families I think we don't have
to hesitate to get some psychological
help it's important the psychological
state of the driver is now under sharp
Focus Laval Transit bus driver piagni
Saint ammo is charged with two counts of
first-degree murder Witnesses say the
driver was hysterical that when he got
off the bus he was naked and screaming
incoherently four people wrestled the
suspect to the ground before police
brought him into custody this man is
Saint Emma's next door neighbor I used
to see him like playing with his kids
outside what happened we should know
everybody should know
how this could have happened is one of
many lingering questions was he on duty
was he supposed to work if not how did
he manage to pick up a bus and was there
a particular event that sort of set off
this mechanism the Quebec government
says there's no evidence at this point
he had a mental health disorder or was
seeking treatment my first question
would be looking back into his his
history a little bit do we see that
typical pattern of social isolation was
he really on his own
for all the confusion and sadness there
are also signs of strength hundreds of
people are gathered here outside this
church in Laval they're standing
shoulder to shoulder in the cold to show
their respects laying flowers and
lighting candles in honor of the two
children who died Donna all right turia
Israel and Lavelle Quebec tonight thanks
and there is more sad news from Quebec a
fire at a home about an hour's Drive
North of Montreal has taken a terrible
toll by the time fire Crews arrived
early this morning they say the house in
Saint Jacques was destroyed they
initially discovered four bodies inside
and later found two others authorities
say two adults are dead plus four
children all of whom are under the age
of eight neighbors say a family lived in
the house but the identities of the Dead
have not been confirmed the provincial
police's major crime unit is now
investigating
the Ukrainian president's in-person plea
coming up his request and his powerful
message to the European Union Plus I in
the sky what the U.S says Beijing spy
balloon was capable of
[Music]
Ukraine's president has made a third
stop on his first major tour outside his
country since Russia's Invasion last
year today he addressed the European
Parliament in Brussels and he was warmly
embraced as he was in Paris and London
but he was there for more than moral
support he wants fighter jets and more
weapons Reggie cicchini reports
greeted with a hero's welcome Ukraine's
president walked towards a future he is
adamant his country will reap the
benefits of namely the ideals and
security that the European Union offers
ukrainians want to live like in the
European Union that means democracy rule
of law diversity the Strategic objective
is clearly said Ukraine is you the EU is
Ukraine let's make it happen this is
Vladimir zielinski's first visit to this
Parliament where Ukraine is a candidate
for membership but staring down a long
road free Europe Cannot Be Imagined
without free Ukraine he says not lost is
the sense of urgency the coming weeks
and months will be crucial the West is
stepping up with more military hardware
and on Tuesday
Vladimir zielinski also hinted some EU
leaders appear ready to offer aircraft
that would Mark a significant Turning
Point following fears it could draw
countries across a Russian Red Line we
should not fall into the strap of
discussing Russian red lines we should
be discussing the lines of international
rule-based order of course none of that
is on an official record but even a
conversation is a testament to how this
one man can influence the International
Community I think a lot of this is
probably quite personally humiliating
from Putin who thinks that he's the one
who by rights should be you know shaking
hands and taking group photos in
Brussels and well Ukraine's president
leaves this trip empty-handed he won't
return home with empty promises
Reggie chickenie Global News Washington
and Global News will Air a special on
February 25th mark one year since the
full-scale Russian invasion of Ukraine
senior officials in the U.S state
Department say the Chinese balloon that
flew over the U.S for eight days was
equipped with multiple antennas likely
capable of collecting and geo-locating
Communications and they say it was part
of a larger Fleet of surveillance
balloons operated by the Chinese
military the U.S says it is preparing to
bring up more fragments of the balloon
much of which remains underwater it was
shot down off the coast of South
Carolina the state department says
China's military is likely behind the
surveillance program and the China has
flown similar balloons over more than 40
countries across five continents the
Chinese government denies that accusing
the U.S of a campaign of information
Warfare against China North Korea's
leader oversaw massive parade of
military might on Wednesday night and by
his side was a girl believed to be Kim
jong-un's second oldest child she is
thought to be 9 or 10 years old and it's
the fifth public appearance she's made
in three months fueling speculation she
could be her father's successor the
parade to celebrate the 75th anniversary
of the founding of North Korea's Army
showcased almost almost a dozen of what
Security Experts believe are Advanced
intercontinental ballistic missiles more
than have ever appeared at one of these
extravagant parades
Saskatchewan stabbings ahead what a
9-1-1 call reveals about last year's
horrific events
it's been five months since that violent
stabbing Rampage in Saskatchewan that
left 11 people dead at the time Global
News reported the wife of one of the men
initially considered a suspect Damian
Sanderson had called the RCMP the day
before the murders Global News has
obtained the audio of that 9-1-1 call
reporter Nathaniel Dove explains what's
in it and how it sheds new light on the
case
are we seeing people in Journey calling
from 306. yes they own James Smith yes
24 hours before the massacre at Jamie
Smith Cree Nation and in nearby Weldon
Saskatchewan Sky Sanderson called for
help I'm sincere because I have several
domestic charges against so many hasn't
been picked up yet the 9-1-1 call and
incident report obtained by global
news's Ashley Stewart using a privacy
act request shows that one day before
miles Sanderson killed 11 people and
injured 18 Sky reported miles's brother
Damien her husband to RCMP saying he
took her SUV and was known to be violent
Damien spent most of the day before the
stabbings with Miles RCMP say Skye did
not mention miles in her call so now
he's uh driving around and I got a
couple of phone calls from family
members that he's uh like like harassing
them acting on calls with Skye officers
did find her stolen car and they spoke
to Damien but they didn't recognize him
and they didn't ask for ID the males in
the residence were asked to identify
themselves
none of them identified as Damian
Sanderson
the keys for the stolen vehicle were
recovered from inside the residence Sky
tells Global News she told officers they
were using an old photo and that she
wishes they double checked who they were
talking to and I don't get money they
didn't go back and
a lawyer cautions it's not that simple
officers can only ask for ID under
certain conditions the police would have
also have to ask themselves is anyone in
danger Hillary Peterson says officers
likely could have in this case but says
there may have been no need since they
recovered the car keys and no one was
apparently at risk Global News asked
RCMP for comment in a statement they
said the 9-1-1 call was released in
error and is part of an ongoing active
investigation so we are unable to
comment Sky wishes officers had
recognized Damien she lost her husband
and her father in the attack and says
they'd still be alive if police did more
Nathaniel Dove Global News Saskatoon
if you want to listen to Sky sanderson's
full 9-1-1 call and learn what she knew
about the Killer's past acts of violence
you can go to our website globalnews.ca
global national